kate when we think about some of the
lessons that you guys learned from this
um in the report you guys call out a
couple of kind of key learnings i'll
call them uh one of them is high
multiples uh which it almost has become
like a uh uh um a joke at this point
right in terms of everyone's like oh of
course the multiples are high it's just
like how high can they go how do you
guys think about that as you've been uh
kind of watching this play out over the
last couple of years as you've been
reporting on the tech industry like is
this something that's just cyclical and
eventually kind of comes down or is
there something that's kind of quote
unquote you know it's different this
time that that you think sticks i mean i
think there's probably two answers to
that and one is specifically about
crypto and one is about the wider
industry but yeah at this point we do
expect to see you know 100 or even 200x
multiples or higher and they are
ridiculous and they they will come down
but it's something that we come to
expect so it wouldn't hurt or help
a company if we're trying to decide
whether it should make the list um when
it comes to crypto i do think those
multiples are getting larger larger
larger i think that they'll continue to
rise through next year um depends on who
you ask though some people are much more
skeptical about what's happening with
the web 3 movement and the explosion and
venture capital interest in crypto which
is
incredibly new um and historically you
know wasn't there so i think that'll
last through 2022 but um
i'm sure hannah saw that a lot when she
was trying to put her list together i
focused on fintech and that has been a
sector that for the last several years
has been really
exploding and the multiples and the
valuations have been growing growing and
i think we're starting to see maybe some
of that
excitement diminish a little bit as vcs
sort of shift over to crypto though
there is an intersection between crypto
and fintech you know more exclusively
crypto companies
makes sense and then in terms of uh the
list and the learnings uh
i actually thought that one of the most
interesting sections was uh also the
venture capitals that showed up the most
and i think that we usually think about
the companies and and uh kind of what
they're building what their product what
their valuations their revenue etc uh
but kate there's a whole section on um
you know everyone from andreessen the y
combinator to uh founders fund then even
in china you guys break down kind of
some of the big uh investors there was
there anything that was surprising about
this or is it kind of the story lines
that people know that you know the
tigers of the world the andreas they're
just deploying you know an immense
amount of money and so of course they're
gonna be in a ton of deals
i no i don't think there's anything
surprising about it i think that
that one of the themes we've written
about this year is that andreessen and
tiger you know are dominating venture
capital they've done they probably each
done maybe close to 200 deals i'm not
hundreds of deals this year tiger i
think actually is probably near 400 so
like essentially one deal per day um
which we have not seen that before and
they've kind of as we've said they've
sort of changed and disrupted
the venture capital industry by being so
active in their deal making this year
so when we were putting the list
together i think we really expected to
see them show up a lot um and of course
i mean andreessen and is just has proven
that they they have a strategy of sort
of
outpacing their competitors and i mean
especially crypto as you all know
they were much earlier to the category
in raising their first crypto fund in
2018 and have doubled down on it far
ahead of competitors who are just kind
of realizing in the last say
six months that this is a category that
they need to understand and invest in
talk to me about tiger they've got
almost 100 billion dollars of assets
under management what what is like your
general take in terms of uh their
strategy what do you hear other people
talking about do people like them not
like them do people think that they are
uh kind of you know smart investors do
they think that they're just kind of
spreading capital like what are you
hearing
so tiger is a really small team and like
i said they've done
basically one deal a day and these are
not small investments these are very big
typically growth stage investments um
though they are kind of going at all
stages which is interesting um i think
that people think they are smart they
have a very specific strategy which is
to invest the capital and then walk away
from the company basically meaning you
know they they will give you your 200
million dollar check and maybe they'll
check in with you
once a quarter or maybe a little more
often than that and just be like how's
it going um they also provide their
companies access to consulting firms who
will help them out
versus a traditional firm would probably
themselves offer that resource
they're very hands-off and i think
people
respect that they are just going to be
incredibly
accelerated in their investing pace and
yet know that they can't be involved
with all their companies i think if they
tried to be as helpful as a traditional
firm like an andreas and horowitz which
is a more of
a
model that is hands-on they would not be
successful but the fact that they're
willing to just walk away from each deal
and just be like yeah that's who we are
we're not going to be hands-on i think
people respect that